The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Good
afternoon, everybody.
Let me just remind
you where we are.
We're describing
interaction between
the electromagnetic
field and atoms.
And we had formulated
an exact approach
using the time evolution
operators and diagrams.
And well, I think
we understood what
it means when atoms in
the ground state emit
photons which are virtually
absorbed and all that.
So we figured out what is
really inside this formalism
and what are the processes.
What we want to continue
discussing today
is one problem which you
often have such approaches.
And this is the
problem of resonance.
If you have a
perturbative treatment,
even if you carry
to infinite order,
you have, formally,
divergences if you
have resonant interaction.
Because the ground
state and the photon
has exactly the same energy
as the excited state.
And that means if you write
down the perturbative expansion,
you have a 0 in the denominator.
You have a divergence.
And I reminded you that
in a phenomenological way,
you've seen that this
problem can be "fixed"
by adding an imaginary
part to the energy level
just saying, well,
the excited state
couples by spontaneous emission
to the radiation field.
And the level has [INAUDIBLE].
Well, but you know, sometimes
putting an imaginary part
into Schrodinger's
equation means
it's no longer unitary
time evolution.
It has its problem.
But anyway, we want to
now look deeper into it.
I want to show you
what are the tools
to treat those infinity
source divergences
in a consistent and
a systematic way.
And one hint how we have to
do it comes by simply taking
this energy denominator and
expanding it in gamma, simply
a Taylor expansion in gamma.
And then, we realize
gamma is often
calculated in second
order Fermi's golden rule.
But since you have
here all orders n,
that tells us that
doing something here
probably means infinite orders
in a perturbation series.
And that's what I want
to show you today.
I want to show you that I
can go beyond this result.
But I can reproduce
this result by going
to infinite order in
perturbation theory.
And it means to sum up an
infinite number of diagrams.
Who of you have
actually seen those kind
of diagrammatic
tricks and summation?
A few, OK.
So it's maybe nice
to see it again.
But for those who
haven't seen it,
welcome to the
magic of diagrams.
I learned it from
those examples.
And I really like it.
It's a very elegant way
to combine equations
with graphical manipulations.
So that's our agenda for at
least the first part of today.
And OK, we want to
understand the time
evolution of this system.
Our tool is a time
evolution operator.
And at the end of
the class on Monday,
I told you, well,
let's simplify things.
Let's get rid of those
temporal integrations
and multiple integrals by simply
doing a Fourier transform.
Because a Fourier
transform turns an integral
or convolution into a product.
And so therefore, we introduced
the Fourier transform,
or the Laplace transform, of
the time evolution operator.
And this iterative equation
where we get the nth order
by plugging the n
minus first order
on the right hand side,
this iterative equation
turns now into a simpler
algebraic iterative
equation for the
Fourier transform.
So this is now the starting
point for our discussion today.
We want to calculate the Fourier
transform of the time evolution
operator to infinite orders.
So let me-- well, of course,
any questions before I continue?
So unfortunately, [INAUDIBLE].
We should copy this equation.
Because we need it.
So OK, we want to
take this equation.
And now we want to iterate it.
So the resolving G
in 0's order is G0.
Now plug G0 into the right
hand side of the equation,
and you get the first
order, which is G0VG0.
Now plug that into the end
of the iterative equation,
and you get the second
order, G0VG0VG0.
I think you've got the idea.
It's almost like a
geometric series--
well, a geometric
series with operators.
But this is already
sort of a hint.
A geometric series can be summed
up to infinity rather easy.
So we have to introduce
now the eigenfunctions
of the unperturbed operator.
So these are, let's say, the
ground state, excited state,
next excited state of
your favorite atom.
And they have
eigenenergies Ek-- nope.
So if you are now expressing
the equation above in the basis
kl-- so in other words,
this is an operator,
and we want to know
the matrix element
between eigenfunctions k and l.
The other thing we
need is that G0.
Remember the Fourier
transform-- and I
gave you sort a mini
derivation here-- is just 1
over energy minus H. And if you
apply that now to the operator
G0, so G0 is nothing
like-- is given by that.
So therefore, if you
write now this equation
as matrix elements,
the first part, the G0,
gives us 1 minus
1 over Z minus Ek.
And since we are diagonal
in H0, it's delta kl.
And well, now you
see the structure
if you sum over
intermediate states,
or if you introduce
intermediate states.
So this is how we
have to write it.
So this is just writing
it down in basis function
of the unperturbed operator H0.
But now we can formulate the
problem we are encountering
and we want to solve.
Namely, we have the
problem with one state.
Our problem is the
excited state b.
And we have a
resonant excitation
from the count state a.
So this is a discrete eigenstate
of the unperturbed Hamiltonian
with energy Eb.
And therefore, we have terms,
and actually divergent terms,
which are 1 over Z minus Eb.
And just to make
the connection, this
is sort of the description that
book Z is in the complex plane
and can have imaginary values.
Sometimes, scattering
and evolution equations
are better formulated when you
do it in the complex plane.
It doesn't really
matter for us here.
Just remember, Z is the energy.
And it is the initial energy.
And the initial
energy is if it's
a ground state and a resonant
photon, we have a problem.
Because the denominator is 0.
So in other words, for
resonant excitation,
we are interested
in the case that Z
is on the order of
this close to Eb.
OK, so what we
want to do now is--
and this is the basic idea.
By looking at this
formally, exact calculation,
we say the difficult parts are
those where we have this energy
denominator, which vanishes.
The other parts are simple.
They don't have any divergences.
They are not resonant and such.
So what we want to do
is now, in some way,
we want to sort of
give special treatment,
factor out the
problematic terms.
And the rest is easy.
And for the easy part,
which has no divergence,
we can make any kind
of approximation
we want without
altering the physics.
But the resonant part, this
needs special attention.
Because if I treat it
literally in those expressions,
they don't make
sense mathematically.
Because they cause infinities.
I could continue to do it
completely algebraically.
But because I think it's
just beautiful method,
I want to look at this equation
and write it down in symbols.
So we want to arrive at a
diagrammatic representation
for this matrix element
of the resolvent Gbb.
And I use symbols where the
circle means the interaction.
The straight line stands for
the term which is problematic,
which has resonant-- the
resonant interaction has
the divergent denominator.
And then, I'll use a dashed
line for all other terms,
all other intermediate
states, where i is not b,
and therefore there
is not a problem.
It's not resonant.
We don't have a divergence.
So I'm just sort of-- you
see the structure of the sum.
We sort of propagate here.
We make a transition
from l to k.
And then, we propagate here.
So in this kind of order,
you start in this state,
you have a vertex, you go to the
other state, you have a vertex,
you go to the next
state, you have a vertex.
This is how the system works.
This is sort of what quantum
mechanics does for you.
And what we're going to do is,
this is an algebraic equation.
And now we want to order
them in the following way.
We want to figure out
which of those expressions
include this problematic term
exactly twice or three times
or four times.
So we regroup those infinite
sums, these algebraic terms,
in such a way that
we say, OK, which
one has the occurrence of
this once, twice, three times,
four times?
So we regroup the terms, and
then we see what we can do.
Now, I've picked the
matrix element Gbb.
So that means over
here and over here
we start out in the state b.
So if I write down
all terms which
contain this
resonant term twice,
well, we start with
a resonant term.
And we have to end
with a resonant term,
because we have
the matrix element
Gbb, which I'm focusing now on.
And so there can be one vertex.
We can start with this term.
And now we can do
something else in between.
But we are not allowed to
go back to the state b.
Because we are only
looking at terms
where the solid
line appears twice.
So therefore, this can only be
a dashed line, another state.
We can go through two vertices.
But it can only include
dashed lines in between.
So let me use another
symbol for it.
So we start with that state.
We end with a state b.
But in between, we can sort
of once, twice, three times
go through other
intermediate states.
But we never are allowed to
create another divergence.
And this infinite
sum over all other
states-- I don't know
how to calculate it yet.
But I'll just call
it a square box.
So in other words, what is
sort of in lowest order,
the operator V, with these
other infinity terms,
I symbolize that kind of much
more complicated vertex, which
includes an infinite sum, by
a square and not by a circle.
So diagrammatically--
feel free to write it down
mathematically.
It's obvious how to do it.
The square box is the circle
plus all terms like this.
Let's go back to equations.
We call this the
function Rb of Z.
And what I've shown
in diagrams above
is nothing else than the
circle Vbb, the matrix element
of the interaction.
But now we have
sums where we're not
allowed to go through
the resonant state.
We have to go from b to
an intermediate state.
We propagate in the
intermediate state.
And then, we have to go back.
And it's clear how to
go to higher terms.
So we've just defined
this function R
by focusing on two occurrences
of the straight line.
Well, let's look at
higher order terms.
What happens when Z minus
Eb, the divergent term,
comes to the power n?
Well, we just dealt
with n equals 2.
Let's now look at n equals 3.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: I'm trying
to find the definition.
Is the box a T-matrix
or the S-matrix?
What's the definition
of the [INAUDIBLE].
The S is--
PROFESSOR: No, the
T-matrix is actually
the matrix, the relevant matrix,
of the time evolution operator.
And if you factor out the delta
function for the energy shell,
you get the S-matrix.
But we're not talking about a
time evolution operator here.
We're talking about
the Fourier transform.
And we're looking at
the resolvent, which
is the function G. And now,
we've introduced a function R.
I actually tried to
look up-- I wanted
to use the correct
word in class.
I couldn't find the name.
In the book, it's just
called the function R.
So it is the function R.
And the function R turns out
to be the kernel of the
resolvent G. But none of it
is the S-matrix and T-matrix.
It is related.
Because if you do the inverse
Fourier transform from G,
we go back to U.
And then, we have,
I would say, the T-matrix.
AUDIENCE: This is
the self energy?
PROFESSOR: We will find that R
has a real and imaginary part.
One is a self energy,
and the other one
is a decay rate, has
an imaginary part.
But the real part will
be the self energy.
Yes, we connect a
lot of passwords
you may have heard
here and there.
OK, the question is, do
we have to now define
pentagons and hexagons?
Do we have to find
more and more symbols
for more and more
complicated sums?
But the nice thing is no.
Because n equals 3 means we
have to start in state b.
We have to stand in state b.
And one time in
the time evolution,
we can go through state b.
And now, between that, we
can go from here to there
with any combination
of states you want.
But one thing is not allowed--
to involve the state b.
Because we are focusing on three
occurrences of the state b.
And everything else
other than the state b
has already a symbol.
It is the square symbol.
So this is the exact
representation for n equals 3.
And the contribution
to the resolvent
G, the Fourier transform of
the time evolution operator,
is-- well, we have factored out
three occurrences of the state
b.
And then, we have three
occurrences of the state b.
We need two square boxes.
But the square box
has already a name
and an algebraic definition.
So this is nothing
else than-- I think
it's called the
kernel Rb squared.
OK, I've shown you n equals 2.
I've shown you n equals 3.
I assume it's now absolutely
clear how to continue.
It just involves
more and more power.
So the lowest order is that.
And whenever we ask
what happens when
we allow more appearances of
the state b, for each of them,
we obtain another square box.
So by looking at the
terms which are bothersome
and regrouping
the infinite terms
according to one occurrence,
two occurrence, three
occurrence of this
divergent denominator,
we have now found an exact
expression for Gb of Z.
And since this is now
an algebraic equation
with a geometric series,
we can write it exactly
as this minus Rb of Z.
Well, like with
every exact result,
you have to ask, what
is the use for it?
Because we started
out with U, which
we couldn't calculate
with Fourier transform.
We had G, which we
couldn't calculate.
And now we've expressed G in
R, which of course we cannot
calculate exactly.
But there is an importance.
We have made progress for
the following reasons.
Namely, the first is that
those resonant terms, which
appears in the time evolution
whenever the system goes back
to the state b, is now
fully accounted for.
We have sort of factored
those terms out.
We've given them
special treatment.
And therefore, and this is the
main result, the exposition
which now is the non-trivial
expression, the function
of the kernel, has
no divergences.
And therefore, because there
is no critical part to it,
rather simple
approximations can be made
and lead to physically
meaningful results.
That's an idea you may
see often in physics.
You have a theory whether
it's something complicated,
non-perturbative divergence.
But you just rewrite the
theory, transform the equations
in such a way that
structure of the equations
now accounts for the
physics behind it.
And the part which has
to be calculated now
can be calculated with
crude approximation.
And you still get the
correct physics out of it.
The structure of the equation
accounts for the physics.
And the numerical part
has become very harmless.
But what it does is even if
you do now a lowest order
approximation to
the function R, even
those very simple
approximations correspond
to an infinite number of terms
in the original expansion.
Or in other words, the message
is, you have an expression.
And if you do a perturbative
expansion-- well,
maybe you should do some form
of perturbative expansion
not to the whole expression.
You should do it
to some denominator
or to some part of
the denominator.
Because then, the
perturbative expansion
involves no divergent
terms and can be performed.
So therefore, we are
now in a position
to make approximations
to the function R.
And the simplest
approximation which we can do
is we can just try to
see if we can get away
with very low order.
It's maybe not getting
into any divergences here.
And let me call this
now the triangle.
So the circle was the
naked interaction.
The square would be
the exact function
if you sum up those
interactions to all orders.
And the triangle is now,
well, the step in between.
We hope to get away
with a triangle.
So that would mean
the following,
that the exact formulation
involved-- let me get black--
had a propagator.
The state b has to go
through multiple squares.
This is how it propagates.
This would be the exact
result after the resummation
we have done.
And an approximate result
is now that the squares
are replaced by triangles.
So that's pretty neat.
But the importance comes now
when I pull things together,
I want to show you
what we have exactly
done for treating an
atom in the excited state
and for treating
light scattering.
So in other words,
that's our result.
We have derived it.
I just go now and apply to
an excited atomic state.
So the state we
are interested in
is the atomic state
b and no photons.
And the property
of the atomic state
is obtained when we know
the function Gb of Z.
Just to tell you what it means,
this is the time evolution
operator when we
Fourier transform,
an inverse Fourier or Laplace
transform, which is a contour
integral in the complex plane,
a generalization of the Fourier
transform.
This would take us then
to the time evolution
for the atom in state b.
So this is now the diagram
matrix element of the T-matrix.
And this is the matrix element
between state B0B0 and the time
evolution operator.
So we are calculating,
of course,
the Fourier transform of the
time evolution of the state
b by the Fourier transform
through the resolvent G.
And all the work we have
done with our diagrams
means instead of
calculating G, we
are calculating the
kernel of Z. And if you
use the lowest second
order approach, then
diagrammatically-- just give me
one second, photon was emitted.
Yeah, sorry, so the
process we have considered
is that we go to second order.
We can go through an
intermediate state,
can say, absorbing it and
meeting a virtual photon.
That's what two vertices mean.
At the first vertex,
the photon appears.
At the second vertex,
the photon disappears.
So that means now that we,
with this approximation,
approximate Gb of Z, the Fourier
transform, the resolvents,
in the following way.
We let b just propagate,
which is problematic
because this has divergences.
But we are allowing
now the state b
to go through
intermediate states a.
And remember, since this
appears in the denominator, that
means for G, just make
a Taylor expansion in R,
that it has this
process to all orders.
So that propagator, the
sort of propagation G,
involves now all
possibilities that we
have to end up in state b again.
But we can go through
intermediate states
a or a prime as
often as we want.
Or actually, we
have summed it up.
Our results contain those
processes to infinite order.
So the question is,
what have we neglected?
I mean, that looks like a lot.
We allow the state b to emit
a photon, go to another state.
It's reabsorbed and such.
So the question is
now, what is neglected?
So what we neglect
is actually a lot.
In this lowest order
approximation for the function
R, we approximated
R by second order.
We have only two vertices.
So what we neglect
are all processes
where we have not
just two vertices
and one intermediate
states, where
we have several intermediate
states between two
occurrences of the state B0.
Or diagrammatically,
what we have neglected
is-- let me just
give you an example.
So what we have neglected
is we have to always start
with a state b, and we
have to end with a state b.
But now the idea
was that-- one, two,
let me just go
through four vertices.
The approximation
we have done-- you
have to sort of look through
that maybe after the lecture
and see that that's
what we've really done,
but trust me-- is that when the
system goes away from the state
b into an intermediate
state a, at
the next vertex it has to
go back to the state b.
So what we have not
included is processes
where we go through states
a, a prime, a double prime,
and then eventually we
go back to the state a.
Or we have not included
processes where we scatter,
absorb.
This is a state a.
But then, we don't go back to b.
We go to a prime.
Then, we scatter again.
Here we are in state
a double prime.
And then, we are back in b.
So in other words, we have said
whenever something happens,
and we go away from
state b, the next vertex
has to go back to state b.
This is the nature of the
lowest order approximation.
We have included
to infinite order
all processes where the
state b emits a photon,
reabsorbs it, emits
and reabsorbs it.
But the system cannot go sort
of two steps away from the state
b.
It's only one step,
and then go back.
This is the nature
of the approximation.
OK, so our result
for this kernel,
which describes the state b,
is we have-- just go back,
let you see it again.
I'm writing now for you down
the equation for the triangle,
which is an interaction
V, an intermediate state,
and another interaction V, which
is nothing else than Fermi's
golden rule where we-- well,
with a little twist-- have
the initial state.
The dipole interaction or
the [? p.a ?] interaction
takes us to an
intermediate state
with a photon with [INAUDIBLE]
and polarization epsilon.
We propagate in the
intermediate state Ea.
And now we have to go back.
But we have to go back with
the same matrix element.
So therefore the matrix
element is squared.
And we have a double sum.
We sum over all possible
states of the photon.
And we can sum over all
intermediate atomic states.
Yes, so this is
what we have done.
This expression has in general
a real part and imaginary part.
It's a function of
the initial energy E.
And it has an imaginary part.
Yes, let me now
interpret it in two ways.
But before I do that,
are there any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just
mathematically, how do you
get an imaginary
part out of this?
It's all real
components, because we
have magnitude squared
divided by, presumably,
the energies real and so on.
PROFESSOR: OK, this
is now something
to do that we have
resonant terms.
And what we often do is we
add an infinitesimal eta,
and then let eta go to 0.
And it's the same if you
have the function 1 over x.
And look at a real part
and imaginary part.
It needs a little bit
of correct treatment
of functions in
the complex plane.
Let me actually write it down.
Then it becomes clear.
But yes, thanks
for the question.
So I always said, we
do a Fourier transform,
but it's a Laplace transform.
We do a Fourier
transform at real energy.
But if you do an
integration along when
you do the Fourier
transform, you
have to integrate over omega.
But the function we integrate,
the time evolution operator,
has poles in omega.
So we can't just
Fourier transform.
Because we go right
through the poles.
But what we can do is we can add
an imaginary part plus or minus
eta.
And we can just go
around the poles.
And then, it becomes
mathematically meaningful.
And what we're doing here
is-- but I'm not really
explaining it
mathematically-- we
have played those tricks here.
But I hope it becomes
clear if I say
what the real and
imaginary parts are.
So the real part is
this matrix element
squared, but double sum.
But what we use is the
principle part of it,
which is well defined in the
theory of complex functions.
And it's divergent, but you
take a certain symmetric
limiting procedure.
So you have to
interpret that as-- you
have to introduce a limiting
procedure to make sure
that the divergence cancels out.
And the imaginary part, value of
the imaginary part of something
which diverges-- and if you
treat the eta correctly,
let the eta go to 0, you will
realize that the imaginary part
turns into a delta function.
So what we get is
2pi over H bar matrix
element squared times
the delta function.
So that's something
which you have seen.
So the imaginary part gets
us Fermi's golden rule.
And the real part has
actually-- remember
when we discussed
the AC Stark shift.
The AC Stark shift has a 1
over [INAUDIBLE] dependence.
And you recognize that here.
So this is actually nothing
else than the AC Stark
shift not due to a laser beam,
but due to one photon per mode.
Because we started with an
atom in an excited state.
It can emit a
photon in any mode.
And this photon is now
creating an AC Stark shift.
And this is mathematically
the expression.
And such AC Stark shifts
which appear as self energies,
as energy shifts created
by the state, this
is nothing else than
the famous Lamb shift.
So that's what we get out here.
I have already--
do I in this sum?
What we have here is
we have this function R
in the real and imaginary part,
which depends on the energy E.
But remember, we worked so
hard with diagrams to make sure
that the triangle-- first the
square, and then the triangle,
and this is what
we calculate here--
has no resonant structure
at the energy Eb.
So therefore, we can neglect
the energy dependence of that
and simply replace the
argument E by the energy
we are interested in,
namely energies close to Eb.
So in other words, when we had
the function, the resolvent Gb
of Z, all the dependence on
energy came from this kernel.
But this kernel is now
so well-behaved, there
are no resonant terms, that
we can neglect its energy
dependence.
This actually has a name
which we will encounter later
when we discuss master equation
and optical Bloch equations.
So this replace, neglect
E and set, or replace
the dependence by E,
by taking the value
at Eb, this corresponds to
the Markov approximation.
The Markov approximation
often means
that some relaxation time
or some response of a system
is replaced by delta function.
Well, we've done the same here.
Because if you replace some
temporal response function
by a delta function, that
means the Fourier transform
becomes constant.
And by neglecting the
energy dependence,
we are now saying everything
is constant as a function
of energy.
And that means in
the temporal domain
that we have a delta function.
I don't want to go further here.
But when we talk about
the master equation,
we will also make a
Markov approximation
later on, but then in
the temporal domain.
And the two are equivalent here.
So what we've got
now is we found
a solution for the Fourier
transform of the time evolution
operator, which initially
had a divergence at energy b.
And this was the
problem we are facing.
But by now, calculating
the function R,
we have a correction, which
is a radiative shift, which
comes from the real part.
And we obtained, as
promised, the imaginary part,
which we can approximate
by Fermi's golden rule.
If we now Fourier transform back
and obtain the time evolution
of this state, it no longer
evolves with the energy Eb.
It has a shifted energy
by this self energy.
And this is called
the radiative shift.
But in addition, because
of the imaginary part,
it has now an exponential decay.
And you should now-- well, this
is what we may have expected.
But there are two
things you should learn.
The first thing is that
the exponential decay
would be different if we had not
made the Markov approximation.
If we had kept a dependence of
this imaginary part on energy,
the Fourier transform
would not have simply
given us an exponential.
So therefore, the
exponential decay
involves an approximation
that the R function
has no energy dependence.
And you would say, well,
is that really possible?
If you have an
atom, and it decays,
or you have the atom in state
b, at very, very short times
you need Fourier
transform elements
of large amounts of energy.
So maybe for the first
femtosecond for the time
evolution of an excited
state, you need whatever,
a whole X-ray
spectrum of energies.
And it's obvious that the
properties of this expression
where you sum over
all states, something
will happen when you go
past the normal excitation
energy or the ionization
energy of the atom.
So what you can
immediately read form here
is that exponential decay
is a simple approximation.
It works very well.
But at very early times,
it will break down.
Because then, the energy
dependence matters.
But the longer you wait-- if
you wait a few nanoseconds,
the Fourier transform, the
relevant part of the Fourier
transform, is only a small
energy or frequency interval
around the resonance energy.
And then, the density of
states of your photon field
is pretty much
constant around here.
And then, this
approximation is excellent.
So I hope what you have
learned from the treatment
is number one, where the
exponential decay comes from.
Of course you knew that
from coupling to all modes,
but that the approximation
which leads to exponential decay
would also involve
the density of states
and the density of
modes is constant,
which is excellent
for certain times
but which is of course
violated at early times.
And finally, if we hadn't
done the infinite summation
of diagrams, if we had done
a perturbative expansion,
we would have never
obtained exponential decay.
We would have obtained
some polynominal decay.
Questions about that?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is the
polynominal decay?
PROFESSOR: Some power law.
1 minus the time--
as far as I know,
it would just
involve powers of n.
If you do lowest order
perturbation theory,
instead of getting
an exponential decay,
you would just get
a linear slope.
That's perturbation theory.
And if you fix it, I think
you get quadratic terms.
So it's the sum of power loss.
Of course, an
exponential function
has a Taylor expansion,
which is an infinite sum
of polynominal terms.
And therefore, we need infinite
order to get the exponential.
So it's not really
profound what I'm saying.
It's pretty much an exponential
function is non-perturbative.
Other questions?
So let me wrap up this chapter.
What we have discussed
here is-- I haven't really
discussed resonant scattering.
I've now focused
on the function Gb.
I focused on what
happens to the state b.
But this is-- and this is
what I want to show you now--
the only element we need to
discuss resonant scattering.
So when we have an atom
in the ground state,
and a photon comes along, and
it takes the atom to the excited
state b, then we go
back to the same state--
could be also another state--
by emitting a photon k
prime epsilon prime.
And the relevant matrix element
of the time evolution operator,
which is the T-matrix, involves
now the matrix element,
the initial energy minus
the intermediate energy.
And the critical
part is really--
you can do it mathematically.
I just show it
here as a summary.
The critical part is really
the propagation of the state
b, which is problematic.
But we have now learned,
and it transfers exactly
to the light scattering
problem, that we
have to include now radiative
shifts and an imaginary part
for the decay to
the time evolution.
And that means that this diagram
here for light scattering
has been-- we have
added other terms to it.
And the other terms
are, of course,
that when we scatter light of
an excited state like this,
the excited state can sort of
emit photons and reabsorb them.
And it can do that to--
so we go to that state.
It can do that to
infinite order.
So in other words,
for any problem now
which involves
the excited state,
we replace the 0's order
propagation of the state b.
And mathematically, it means
we replace this function
by the resolvent, which
we have calculated
by doing an approximation
to the kernel R. Questions?
AUDIENCE: Question, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Is this [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
OK, what happens
is if you're off-resonant,
you don't have a problem.
This extra term delta and
gamma, the radiative shift
and the line widths
only matter when
the black term is close to 0.
If you have a large
detuning delta here,
then the small shift in the
line widths don't matter.
So everything we have
done by correcting
the naked propagation
of the state
b by the correct propagation
with this infinite emission
and reabsorption
of virtual photons,
this is only needed if
the denominator is 0.
And then, we have to figure
out what else happens.
And what else
happens is obtained
in higher order with this
non-perturbative treatment.
Other questions?
OK, 20 minutes left.
So we now change gears.
We move onto the
optical Bloch equation.
But let me give you one summary
on this chapter of diagrams.
Until maybe 10, 15
years ago here at MIT,
we were not teaching that.
And I felt often in
discussion with students
that a little bit more of a
complete picture behind atom
photon processes is needed.
What I summarized could of
course cover a whole semester
course in QED and how
to do calculation.
And if you're interested
in mathematical rigor,
the green book,
Atom-Photon Interactions,
is pretty rigorous and
still very physical.
But on the other
hand, many of you
experimentalists,
I think you should
have sort of this picture
behind it, what really happens,
what kind of emission
processes are
responsible for which effect.
And at least this
is sort of for me
a take-home message which
I hope you can enjoy even
without mathematical rigor,
that the fact that the excited
state has [INAUDIBLE] really
comes from an infinite number
of absorption, of emission
and reabsorption processes.
So you should maybe
think about when
you take an atom to
the excited state
that the excited state does more
than just absorb the photon,
the atom is excited,
and then it emits.
The real nature of
this state is that it
couples to many, many modes.
It emits photons
and reabsorbs them.
And you can often neglect
that in the simple description
of your experiment.
But if you take certain
expressions seriously,
they would have divergences.
And that's what we discussed
without this infinite number
of processes which happen.
Of course, yes, the whole
other regime which I should
mention-- and this is
when you can completely
neglect the coupling
to many modes.
If you do Rabi oscillation
with resonant interaction,
you don't need all that.
Because then, you're really
looking at discrete states.
So it really also depends
what you want to describe.
If you do cavity
QED with an atom,
you have the
Jaynes-Cummings model.
And you have an exact solution.
Then you have a
similar mode problem.
But here we have
discussed what happens
if you want to scatter
light in free space.
And then, you have to deal with
the divergence of the excited
state.
OK, the next chapter is called
Derivation of the Optical Bloch
Equation.
And yes, what we really need
for a number of phenomenon
in AMO physics for laser
cooling, light forces, and much
more are the optical
Bloch equations.
But what I try in this
chapter-- to give you
sort of the fundamental
story, the profound story,
the fundamental insight behind
the optical Bloch equations.
Because what the optical Bloch
equations are is the following.
We want to describe
a quantum system.
But the quantum system is
coupled to the environment.
And that means we
have dissipation.
And this is something
which is not easily dealt
with in simple quantum physics.
Because a simply quantum
system undergoes unitary time
evolution described
by a Hamiltonian.
And unitary time evolution does
not allow entropy to increase,
does not allow energies
to be exchanged.
So a lot of things which
happen in our experiments
and in daily life come because
the system we are looking at,
it follows
Schrodinger's equation.
But it is coupled to
a much bigger system.
And so in this
section, what I want
to address at the most
fundamental limit is, what
is the step where we go
from reversible equation,
unitary time evolution, to
something which is called
relaxation, which
is dissipative,
where entropy is increased?
And the step, of course,
is we go from pure states
to statistical operators.
We describe the big system.
But then, we focus
on the small system.
And I want to show you,
first with a simple example,
but next week in
more generality,
how this completely
changes the nature
of the description
of the small system.
A small system which
I just described
by Schrodinger's equation,
now follows the density matrix
equation, has relaxation, the
entropy increases, and such.
So to maybe set the stage,
one of the simplest systems
we can imagine is the
Jaynes-Cummings model,
that we have an atom
in a cavity interacting
with one mode of
the radiation field.
And in this cause in part
one, we've dealt with it
and looked at vacuum Robi
oscillation and a few really
neat things.
But what happens is that the
system is an open quantum
system.
You can have
spontaneous emission.
And if your mirrors are
not 100.00% reflectivity,
some light leaks out.
So in other words, we have
coupling to the environment.
Of course, we can say
we simply describe it.
We have our atoms,
maybe the one mode
plus the one mode of the
electromagnetic field.
And then, we have
the environment,
which may consist of photons
which are leaking out
and photons which are
spontaneously emitted.
So this is our system.
And of course, if you write
down the total Hamiltonian
and do the time
evolution, something
will come out which,
in general, is
very complicated,
very entangled.
The atom is entangled.
The atom moving to
the left side is
entangled with a photon which
was emitted to the right side.
And the recall of the
photons push the atom.
So you have to know, to keep
track of all the photons, which
have been scattered in
the lifetime of an atom.
So you can do that.
And you do that by
propagating the system
with its total Hamiltonian.
But often, what
we do is we simply
put the photons in a trash can.
We trash them.
We're not interested in
what the photons are doing.
We're not keeping track of them.
Actually, they hit the
wall of our vacuum chamber,
and we couldn't even
keep track of them.
The vacuum chamber has
taken care of them.
So all that we are
interested in-- how do we now
describe the atomic system?
What, after the time
evolution, is now
the density matrix
of the system?
Of course, if we use
the full description,
we know the initial
state of the environment.
We know the initial
state or our system.
We propagate it exactly with
the correct time evolution,
we get everything.
And then, we could reduce
by doing a partial trace.
We could reduce the description.
What is now the
probabilistic description
for density matrix of the atom?
But this is rather complicated.
What we want to do is we want
to do it as a derivation.
But in the end, we want to
have a formulation which simply
tells us, what is
the atomic density
matrix as a function of the
initial atomic density matrix?
So in other words, all that
happens with the environment--
that there's initial state,
that it gets entangled,
and then we neglect maybe not
keeping track of the photons--
we're not interested
in all of that.
We really want to focus on
what happens to the atom.
How does an initial
state of the atom
propagate into a final state?
And this is done by
optical Bloch equations.
This is done by the
master equation.
So the master
equation, you can see,
focuses on the relevant part
of the system, maybe just
a single atom.
And we can neglect
the million photons
which have been emitted.
But those million
photons which have
been emitted into
the environment,
they change, of course.
They change this density
matrix of the atom.
And if you find a description,
the master equation
is including with extra terms
what those photons have done.
Maybe this sounds very abstract.
But in the end, you will
find that maybe photons which
emitted produce some damping.
Or if you put atoms in
molasses, the atomic motion
comes to a standstill.
So in other words,
we want to develop
a systematic approximation
scheme for the master equation
whether effect of all these
many, many degrees of freedom
can maybe be simply expressed
by a few damping terms.
So that's the idea.
So yes, you know already one
example of a master equation.
And these are Einstein's
rate equations,
which we have discussed in
the first part of the course.
If you have a two
level system which
is coupled to the
radiation field,
then we obtained
equations that the rate
of change of the
ground state population
is related to the
excited state population
through spontaneous emission
described by the Einstein e
coefficient.
And if you have a
spectral density
of the electromagnetic field,
it causes stimulated emission.
And it causes absorption
described by the Einstein b
coefficient.
And you have a similar
equation for the excited state.
So this is clearly the
semi-classical limit
of what we want to accomplish.
But we want to know more.
We really want to
know not just, what
is the rate equation
for the atom?
We want to know, you can
see, the wave function.
Well, wave function slash
statistical operator--
the statistical
operator contains
all information of
the wave function.
And if the wave function
is a pure state,
it has a certain
statistical operator.
And we can find the pure state.
So that's what we want to do.
But sort of just
genetically, we really
want to find the full
quantum time evolution.
And now I just want
to express that.
We have to be careful.
The time evolution
as a Hamiltonian,
if you now bring
in the environment,
cannot be simply included
by adding an imaginary term.
This here violates the
unitary time evolution.
In other words, when we find
an equation for the quantum
system, how it evolves,
it's not that everything
you think which
phenomenologically works will
work.
It has to be consistent with
the loss of quantum physics.
In other words, when we find an
equation for the statistical--
if you find an equation which
describes the atomic system,
it will be a requirement
that a density matrix
turns into a density matrix.
So certain structure
has to be obeyed.
And that is actually
extremely restrictive.
And our derivation of
the master equation
will actually show what
kind of operators applied
to the atomic density
matrix are consistent, are
quantum mechanically consistent.
This is actually
something-- well,
we're not doing a lot of
equations or work today,
so let me rather be
a little bit chatty.
This is actually something which
is the frontier of our field,
both in theory in ion traps
and with neutral atoms,
that we have some evolution
of an atomic system
by coupling it to
the environment.
Well, the usual environment
you can think of
is just taking photons away.
It gives us a damping
term of the excited state.
But now you can
ask the question,
can you construct
an environment which
has some degrees of freedom
with laser fields, RF
fields, and such?
You call it the environment,
and this environment
does something really fancy.
And the system
comes in equilibrium
with the environment.
But could you engineer
the environment
that the system comes
into equilibrium
with the environment, and
it is in a fancy super fluid
or fancy entangled state?
So can you engineer the
environment in such a way
that it does something
really fancy to your system?
Well, you can dream of it.
But you dreams are restricted
by the mathematical structure
of all possible master
equations in the world.
Because the environment
cannot do everything for you.
The environment
can only do for you
what can come out of all
possible Hamiltonians.
And the fact that
the total system
evolves in a unitary way
with the total Hamiltonian
of the system, this
is really restricting.
This operator sort of stands for
all possible master equations.
It's restricting
the master equation
for your atomic density matrix.
There was just-- I
think was it this year
or last year-- a nice
science and nature paper
by [INAUDIBLE] where
they engineered
the environment around
ions in an ion trap.
And that stabilized
the ion in the state,
which was an unusual state,
not what the normal environment
would have done.
So anyway, what
I will be telling
you is also sort of
relevant to understand
this sort of frontier
in our field which
is called environment
engineering.
OK, density matrix--
good, five more minutes.
So what we have is
we have a system.
And we have this environment.
And what we are exchanging
with the environment
is both energy,
but also entropy.
And so when we transfer
energy or heat,
there is a corresponding
change in energy.
And it's a general property
of all quantum systems.
It's a consequence of the
fluctuation dissipation
principle, the fluctuation
dissipation theorem,
that you cannot have any form
of relaxation without noise.
So for instance, when we
discuss optical molasses--
we do that in a few weeks, where
the atomic motion is damped--
well, you have a damping term.
It seems it brings some
motion through friction
to a standstill.
But we know by
general principles
that damping is not
possible without noise.
So when somebody sells you a
wonderful damping scheme which
damps the motion, you
should always ask,
but there must be noise.
What is the ultimate noise?
And it's fundamental
that it is there.
So therefore, our derivation
of the master equation
will also display
that, that we do not
get any form of damping without
at least the fundamental
quantum noise.
So what we need is we need
a description of the quantum
noise, which comes from
coupling to the environment.
The tool which we use for
that is the density matrix.
I assume everybody here is
familiar with the density
matrix.
The atomic lecture
notes on the wiki
have a small tutorial
on the density matrix
if you want to freshen up your
knowledge about density matrix,
maybe read about it.
I don't want to
cover it in class.
The one thing we need, and
I just want to remind you,
is for all density matrices,
you can always unravel it.
The density matrix
can be written
as a probabilistic
sum over states.
This will actually
play a major role.
We will make certain
models for damping.
And it's really beautiful.
On Monday, I will give you
the beam splitter model
for the optical Bloch equation.
I really like it.
Because it's a
microscopic model.
And it shows you a lot of
fundamental principles.
But the important
part is whenever
we have a way to construct
a density matrix by saying,
we have certain
quantum states k,
and we just add them
up probabilistically,
this kind of microscopic
interpretation of the density
matrix is called unravelling.
It's sort of writing it
as a specific diagonal sum
over states.
But those unravellings
are not unique.
They describe one possibility.
But there are other
possibilities.
And the one example
which I can give you
is that if you have a
density matrix like this,
you can write the density
matrix as this form suggests,
as a probabilistic sum of
being in the state 0, 0,
or in the state 1, 1 with
probability 1/4 and 3/4.
But you can also write it as
being with equal probability
in two states a and b
where the states a and b
are superpositions
of state 0 and 1.
And you can see by inspection
that this will do the trick.
So we'll talk a lot about
unravelling of the density
matrix.
That's why I want
to say up front,
that the same density
matrix can be thought
of as being created by
different processes.
But this actually makes
it even more powerful.
Because we have a unified
description, or even
an identical description,
for different microscopic
processes.
OK, any last questions?
Well then, let's enjoy the open
house with incoming graduate
students, and I'll
see you on Monday.